foreign
thank you
Mr President Mr Provost Madam Secretary
Masters Dean's colleagues friends
families and most of all women and men
of the class of 2014. Welcome To This
Day
congratulations
I now call on the University chaplain
my sisters and my brothers I invite you
to join me in prayer
Almighty and loving God in the Majesty
of this life moment we your beloved
children of different colors Creeds
Generations stories and tongues are
gathered in this place as one human
family united in jubilant celebration
we are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us their
shoulders have boosted us and today
their hearts soar for us
Eternal God it is you who calls us to
our full Humanity
as we celebrate our accomplishments we
are humbled and overwhelmed by what lies
ahead
let us continue to caress the beauty of
your creation and may our souls know
true Delight as we awaken to The Wonder
of our own unfolding lives
through the unity of Mind and Spirit
hold us ever close as we seek to leaven
your world wisely in the steadfast
pursuit of your light and your truth
for this we say Amen
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me
they will bring me to your Holy Mountain
to your Dwelling Place
that I may come to the altar of God
my delight my joy
that I praise you with the harp
oh God my God
you are the light of the world
a City built on a hill cannot be hid
no one after lighting a lamp puts it
under a bushel basket
but on the lamp stand
and it gives light to all in the house
in the same way let your light shine
before others that they may see your
good works and give glory to your father
in Heaven
oh no fire has touched it
light upon light
God guides whom he Wills to his light
God makes Parables for Humanity
and God has knowledge of everything
foreign
it is customary for the president to
deliver a baccalaureate address and for
the dean of Yale College to offer a few
readings
but wait weren't we here just a minute
ago I feel as though you and you and I
were just meeting in your freshman year
did we not Gather in this Grand space
I spoke to you about truth and fiction
and of steps to academic excellence
perhaps you have forgotten the words
but I bet you do recall that there was a
little insert of paper in the program
the image of a Maya chocolate pot you
rolled it into a little paper cylinder
and we raised it on high
let's return to that moment and
celebrate this day with chocolate yes
and with another Native American ritual
which will be part of class day ceremony
as well these and cries of Joy
Ayah all appear in this poem
traditionally attributed to a great
Aztec King and poet nutsawa coyote or
hungry coyote
stand up beat your drum
give of yourself no friendship I
let your hearts be taken with many
colors
only here perhaps are lent to us our
tobacco pipes
our flowers
I drink cocoa with it am I with it I am
glad I
my heart takes pleasure my heart is
Happy Hawaii
as you have traveled through the Yale
curriculum you have changed
you have acquired new knowledge much of
it useful and some of it downright
quirky
you have learned how to ask better
questions
a generation or two learn to ask
questions through a children's
encyclopedia known as The Book of
Knowledge perhaps the addition of 1936
from which this prose poem by a Yale
faculty member is conceived who's black
and cracked spines sat on a shelf in my
family home the reading for Long Winters
stay with me for 17 questions as I take
you to from The Book of Knowledge by
Cynthia Zarin the Otto poems 2010.
one
what makes a fairy ring
fairy rings are a kind of fungus too
why does damp air make us ill
damp air is often cold air and the cold
has usually been blamed for making us
ill though many facts prove that it is
not blameworthy at all
three why does a dog go round and round
before it lies down
the answer to this question lies in
another question what is a dog
four
can our brains ever fill up
the poet Browning says there is no end
to learning
five
why does a tuning fork sound louder when
it touches wood
the sound from a tuning fork like the
light from a candle flows out in all
directions
six
why are some things poisonous we could
only answer this question completely and
fully if we knew all there is to know
about life
seven
why can we hear better when we shut our
eyes
this question is partly true and partly
not true eight can an animal think
eight can an animal think there is no
doubt an animal can think and that it
can remember
nine do animals feel pain as we do that
is not a question that can be answered
directly
10. why do we not growl like animals
when we are hungry
a Hungry Man is an angry man
11. why have leaves different shapes the
great idea which we learned to apply to
every fact about living creatures is
that these facts usually have uses
12.
why did the leaves of the Aspen always
shake the shaking of the leaves has the
same effect as if the trees were Fanning
themselves
13. why does oil make a wheel go round
more easily
it all depends on where the oil is put
14. why do we see the stars only at
night
bars are shining all the time sending
light to Earth but more than this is
needed for us to see
15 is an atom a living thing
it is almost a living thing
16. can country people see Rich small
better than townspeople
if country folk use their eyes mainly at
distances their Vision will be keenest
at distances
17 why does a lump rise in my throat
when I cry
it is the place of speech which is the
most marvelous thing
you arrived here strangers
you looked around this vast Hall
wondering what your path would be and
who you would know and love
as you make your plans to leave
you leave as friends and as I have
prepared these readings I have this year
reflected on my own journey to Yale
37 years ago I came to New Haven to
start a doctorate where I made lifelong
friends especially the best friend I
have also known as my husband
some of you have been my own friends
it's been my great joy to know so many
of you as your Dean I have followed your
steps from Bulldog days until today
and as you 2014 close your career as
students I too will lead my role as Dean
we've been on one Journey did you know
it continues
you may know the poem Ithaca by c p
kavafi hear the familiar lines
as you set out for Ithaca hope the
voyage is a long one full of Adventures
full of Discovery lifestragonians and
cyclops angry Poseidon don't be afraid
of them you'll never find things like
that on your way as long as you keep
your thoughts raised high as long as a
rare excitement stirs your Bot your
spirit and your body
life stragonians and cyclops wild
Poseidon you won't encounter them unless
you bring them along inside your soul
unless your soul sets them up in front
of you
hope the voyage is a long one may there
be many a summer morning when with what
pleasure what Joy you come
Converse seen for the
may you stop at a finish trading station
to buy Fine Things mother Pearl Coral
Amber and Ebony sensual perfume of every
kind as many sensual perfumes as you can
and may you visit many Egyptian cities
to gather stores of Knowledge from their
Scholars
keep Ithaca always in your mind arriving
there is what you are destined for
but do not hurry the journey at all
better if it lasts for years
so you are old by the time you reach the
island wealthy with all that you have
gained on the way not expecting Ithaca
to make you rich
if I could give you the marvelous
Journey without her you would not have
set out she has nothing left to give you
now
and if you find her poor Ithaca won't
have fooled you wise as you will have
become so full of experience you will
have understood by then what these
ithacas mean
translated by Edmund Keeley from the
modern Greek
finally it is a Yale tradition to read a
passage by John Milton on this occasion
you know the story I think there were
these two young 20-somethings maybe they
were even teenagers
um and they were in a garden they
thought it was a perfect place and they
knew that
but they also knew that there was a
world Beyond and they couldn't help but
want to know about it yes as in the
Zarin poem there was a thirst for
knowledge
and also a thirst for Journeys
and then you remember the part about the
wardrobe malfunction
like you and as you may particularly
feel on Monday afternoon or Tuesday
morning
their departure seemed to them sudden
unwarranted abrupt inevitable
from Paradise Lost by John Milton 1667.
some natural tears they dropped but
wiped them soon the world was all before
them where to choose their place of rest
and Providence their guide
they hand in hand with wandering steps
and slow
through Eden took their solitary way
congratulations class of 2014.
foreign
thank you
colleagues friends families graduating
seniors
it's really a pleasure to greet you
today and offer a few words on this
celebratory weekend
over the years I've participated in the
Baccalaureate service in various roles
as a member of the faculty
as a dean
as Provost
and now for the first time as president
now there is a Yale tradition that I've
observed that I would like to continue
today
where we end a year in which we have
introduced new rituals
while also honoring old ones
might I ask all of the families and
friends here today
to rise and recognize the outstanding
and graduating members of the class of
2014.
foreign
that was great
now might I ask the class of 2014 to
consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this Milestone and to
please rise and recognize them
thank you
I Delight in this custom not nearly not
merely because it is lovely in its own
right
but also because my Baccalaureate
remarks today focus on gratitude
I talk about gratitude in part because
I'm so thankful for the dedicated
leadership of Yale College that Dean
Miller has provided since December 2008.
and also in part because gratitude turns
out to be one of the keys to happiness
for most of my adult life I've been a
student of human emotion
it is the basis for my academic career
and one of the passions of my
professional life
and while there is a large and growing
body of scholarly literature On Emotion
it might Supply surprise you
the psychological literature on
gratitude is rather meager
laboratory experiments exploring
gratitude are few and far between
field studies of how children learn to
say thank you are viewed as quaint and
old-fashioned
we all know each of us in our own minds
what it means to be grateful
particularly on a weekend like this one
but until the last decade gratitude
almost never appeared in handbooks and
encyclopedias of human emotions compiled
by psychologists
and the neglect of serious consideration
of gratitude is not limited to
psychology
Aristotle for example did not include it
on his famous list of human virtues
but even if psychology and Aristotle
neglected gratitude many philosophers
from Cicero to Seneca to Aquinas to
Spinoza to Hobbes to Hume can't
many philosophers acknowledge
that the ability to Express gratitude is
not just socially polite
but also a core human capacity
these philosophers worry
that societies characterized by
ungrateful people by ingrates
might be unfair and unjust
and turn to Vengeance and destruction
the fact that there has been so little
attention paid to gratitude in my field
of psychology
the fact that you and I might not pay
enough attention to it
could be because the need to Express
gratitude reminds us
that we are not entirely in control
that we might be indebted
or dependent
that our destiny is not entirely in our
own hands
that on occasion
we are vulnerable
as one of my favorite contemporary
philosophers of emotion the late Robert
Solomon like to say gratitude is an
uncomfortable emotion
because it forces us to recognize that
none of us as holy self-sufficient and
without the need of helped from others
gratitude forces us to reflect on the
limits to our sense of agency
although one's heart might be filled
with gratitude in expressing it might
sometimes feel a bit uncomfortable
even gratitude toward a higher power can
make us squirm if it seems over the top
as when one of my favorite country music
singers thanks the Lord for providing
him with a Grammy award
or even when Big Poppy dramatically
points to the heavens after blessing
blasting a homer over the right field
wall in Fenway Park
I offer my apologies now to any Yankee
fans out there for torturing them with
that image
and yet
true happiness in life
and true Health in society
might not be possible without the
capacity to reject the myth of total
self-reliance
the good life may be Out Of Reach unless
we are able to cultivate an openness to
accepting help from others and
expressing gratitude for that help
in the course of preparing this address
I was thrilled to discover that none
other than Adam Smith an economist known
best for his focus on the importance of
self-interest as a motivating force was
one of the first social scientists to
point out the importance of gratitude
Smith clearly and cogently observed that
passions and emotions are what knit a
society together
sentiments like gratitude Smith argued
make the social World better more
benevolent and more secure well a social
psychologist could not have said it
better
there is no doubt that when we
experience gratitude
it is difficult to feel negative
emotions like Envy anger or hatred at
the same time
in fact people who report that they
express a lot of gratitude people who
respond positively to survey items like
I sometimes feel grateful for the
smallest things and I'm grateful to a
wide variety of people
people who respond positively to those
items also tend to score high on
psychological measures of what is called
subjective well-being that is
satisfaction with their lives
why might that be
well
one human tendency that is incompatible
with expressing gratitude is social
comparison
especially the Insidious tendency to
compare ourselves with those who have
more than we do
it appears that people who feel
gratitude are less likely to Envy others
and thus they avoid an emotion that can
be quite corrosive
moreover grateful people seem to be far
more able to cope with the stresses and
strains of life
they are more resilient
because they find the good even in
difficult circumstances and other people
like them better
what's more
people are more willing to come to the
assistance of others who have expressed
gratitude toward them in the past
to quote that great 21st century
philosopher Justin Timberlake
what goes around comes all the way back
around
psychologist Barbara Fredrickson argues
that feelings of gratitude broaden one's
mind that is they allow you to consider
a wider and more creative array of
possibilities options and alternative
courses of action
this broadening of the Mind produces a
sense of personal resourcefulness and
self-efficacy
Frederickson contends that these
feelings Foster a desire to empathize
with and help other people
and to consider a wider array of
potential ways to be helpful that go far
beyond simple reciprocity or Tit for Tat
the origins of this sort of behavior can
even be observed in non-human primates
like chimpanzees
when one chimp shares food with another
chimp and the chimp who received the
food throws his arms around the food
sharing Chimp in a warm hug
or when one chimp Grooms another chimp
and then a day or two later the
recipient of the grooming shares food
with the groomer
you probably think I got all this from
watching The Lion King
but but as these examples suggest
gratitude might be a key to social
harmony
indeed gratitude May strengthen one
sense of belonging to a community
of obligations to being a good citizen
and of loyalty to the greater good
perhaps this social reinforcement is why
gratitude seems to be observed in
various forms across all cultures
communities in which gratitude is
expressed publicly become knitted
together through a shared sense of
appreciation for everyone's
contributions
public ceremonies and other displays of
gratitude encourage a kind of optimism
and a shared sense of purpose
so let's get back to talking about you
you soon to be graduates of Yale College
you
you are likely feeling gratitude today
the trouble is you owe so much to others
that you can never fully repay them for
the great things you receive in life
and on a day when you are receiving so
much so much warmth so many
congratulations it is always good to
remember that no great gift you have
been given
the opportunity for an education which
you earned but also received no truly
great gift can ever be repaid
instead it must be paid forward and it
is up to you to pass this gift uh gift
on to others in the Next Generation in
the same way you received it
former U.S Poet Laureate Billy Collins
captures these feelings in a poem
written for his mother called the
lanyard
and because Mother's Day was only a week
ago it seems appropriate to read it to
you on this occasion
the other day
I was ricocheting slowly off the blue
walls of this room
moving as if underwater from typewriter
to piano from bookshelf to envelope
lying on the ground on the floor
when I found myself
in the l section of the dictionary
where my eyes fell upon the word lanyard
no cookie nibbled by a French novelist
could send one into the past more
suddenly
a past where I sat at a workbench at
camp
by a deep Adirondack Lake
learning how to braid long thin strips
long thin plastic strips into a lanyard
a gift
for my mother
I had never seen anyone use a lanyard
or wear one if that's what you did with
them
but that did not keep me from Crossing
strand over strand again and again until
I made a boxy red and white lanyard for
my mother
she gave me life and milk from her
breasts
and I gave her a lanyard
she nursed me in many a sick room
lifted spoons of medicine to my lips
laid cold Face clothes on my forehead
and then led me out into the Airy light
and taught me to walk and swim
and I in turn
presented her with a lanyard
here are thousands of meals she said and
here is clothing and a good education
and here is your lanyard I replied
which I made with a Little Help From a
counselor
here is a breathing body and a beating
heart strong legs bones and teeth and
two Clear Eyes to read the world she
whispered
and here I said is the lanyard I made at
camp
and here
I wish to say to her now
is a smaller gift
not the worn truth that you can never
repay your mother
but the rueful admission
that when she took the two-tone lanyard
from my hand
I was as sure as a boy could be
that this useless
worthless thing I wove out of boredom
would be enough
to make us even
so seniors
my message today is not you need to
thank your mothers
although that would not be such a bad
idea
but rather you should spend at least a
few moments
spite of all the hoopla this weekend
thinking about all those individuals who
helped you get to this place in your
lives all those individuals who you can
never repay
they might be family members and Friends
beloved teachers and mentors or even
authors whom you've never met
but think about them and when the moment
is right
say a quiet
thank you
as William Lyon Phelps a distinguished
professor of English at Yale in the
early part of the 20th century once
wrote gratitude
begets happiness
the more one gives
the more one has left
women and men of the class of 2014.
women and men of the class of 2014
congratulations
we are delighted to salute your
accomplishments
we are Overjoyed to celebrate with you
we are proud
of your achievements
remember to give thanks for all that has
brought you to this day
and go forth from this place with
grateful hearts
paying back the gift you have received
here
by paying it forward for others
congratulations
thank you
foreign
go away
may God bless you and keep you
May the Eternal one show you favor and
be gracious to you
May the Holy One cause light to shine
upon you
and Grant you peace
and let us say Amen
thank you
foreign